翻訳: rieko teshima
校正: Hiroko Kawano
♪ 頭フル回転 ♪
♪ 毎日夢描いて ♪
♪ 同じ日々行動に 飽き飽きで ♪
♪ 目の前の壁にさえぎられて ♪
♪ 泣いたって 時過ぎゆくだけで ♪
♪ 息のみ 夢を追いかけて ♪
♪ 気づきゃ 壁なんてな超えれるて ♪
♪ 人に認めてもらい 初めて ♪
♪ 一人前となる ♪
そしてTEDxAnjoの皆さんと
繋がりだす
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
さて —
（笑）
この６％
何を表している数字か
みなさん分かりますか？
これは僕のナンパの成功率では
ありません　（笑）
はい ありがとうございます
これはですね 内閣府の調査で
日本の人口の およそ６％の人が
何らかの障害があるという
割合を表しています
６％というと
小中学校１クラスに だいたい２人程度
なんらかの障害の傾向がある子が
いると言われています
皆さんは６％と聞いて
少ないと感じますか？
それとも多いと感じますか？
僕はラップを通じて
障害があってもなくても
すべての人が対等に支え合うことができる
インクルージョンな社会を
強く願っています
皆さんは 成人した障害をお持ちの方と
一緒にお仕事や活動をしたことはありますか？
僕がインクルージョンな社会を
強く願うようになったのは
今から６年前
はたちで 障害者施設で働き始め
障害のお持ちの方と関わる中で
たとえ会話が難しくても
アイコンタクトだったり
その場の空気だったり
あらゆる形でコミュニケーションできることに
気づきました
また 彼らが持っていて
僕らが持っていないものものにも
気づくことができて
なんていうんですかね
彼らが持っているものに
気づくことができて
健常者と障害者の違いって
いったい何だろうなって
深く考えるようになりました
ラップというのは
どんなジャンルの音楽よりも
伝えたい内容をストレートに
言葉に表現できるので
僕はラップというツールを使って
福祉を社会に
発信しようと考えたのです
これが「韻クルージョン」の始まりです
こちらですね
その一環として福祉施設の中だけに
彼らの才能やすばらしさを
留めてはいけない —
もっと開かれた福祉にしようと思って
福祉発信メディアを立ち上げました
現在もウェブを使い
福祉情報を集めて
記事にして発信しています
このような活動の中で
あらゆる声を集めて
思ったこと感じたことを
歌詞に転換して曲を創っています
障害をお持ちの方にも
参加してもらっています
（動画開始）
♪ ファタ ファタ ファタ タタタ ♪
♪ チーズに ワインに ローストビーフ ♪
♪ シャンパン メロンパン
フフンハン ♪ で行きます
（笑）
何にしましょう？
フフンハンにしますか？
♪ イェーイ イェーイイェーイ イェーイ ♪
♪ まだまだパーティ続けたい ♪
♪ ドラえもんにお願いだあ ♪（イェーイ）
♪ カーニバル（イエーイ）
カーニバル（イエーイ） ♪
♪ オーマイガー 踊ろうよ 歌おうよ ♪
♪ファタ ファタアー♪
（歓声）（拍手）
ありがとうございました
彼らには才能があり
その可能性は無限大 ―
その可能性を一人でも多くの方に
知っていただくために
日々 模索しております
リズミカルに言葉を吐き出すことにより
脳が活性化され
誰もがハッピーになれるのが
音楽の魅力だと思います
ここで 皆さん 僕と一緒に
「韻クルージョン」してみませんか？
今から音楽が流れますので
リズムに乗せながら 僕が
「あいうえお」と言いますので
みなさんも続けて「あいうえお」と
言ってみてください
よろしいですか よろしいですか？
いいですか？
はい それでは ミュージックスタート！
（音楽）
こんな感じで
ヒップホップのビートを刻みながら
「あいうえお」って言ったら みなさんも
「あいうえお」って返してみてください
いいですか？
みなさんもっと
ゆったりゆったりしてくださいね
（笑）
オーケー いきますよ
ワン トゥー ワン トゥースリー
エ ヨ―　♪ あいうえお ♪
（♪ あいうえお ♪）
エヨ―　♪ かきくけこ ♪
（♪ かきくけこ ♪）
エヨー　♪ さしすせそ ♪
（♪ さしすせそ ♪）
エヨー　♪ たちつてと ♪
（♪ たちつてと♪）
エヨー　♪ あんじょう ♪
（♪ あんじょう ♪）
♪ もっと あんじょう ♪
♪ ここが あんじょう？♪
（♪ あんじょう♪）
さ わ げー
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
いかがでしょうか？
楽しくなってきませんか？
はい これがラップの魅力です
誰もが同じように楽しめる
「韻クルージョン」な社会を目指して
今日も歌います
最後に聴いてください
（音楽）
限られた生命で何ができるか？
これが表現の自由
ラップを通じて
どこまでできるか
障害があってもなくても関係ない
これが「韻クルージョン」
聴いてください
♪ 始まりは皆ゼロから ♪
♪ 色のない無色のカラー ♪
♪ 「オギャー」って生まれてから ♪
♪ 時計の針が動き出した ♪
♪ あれから流れる時が ♪
♪ メロディに乗って音が ♪
♪ 波に乗りいつか ♪
♪ 皆の希望に変わる日が ♪
♪ 何もかも投げ出した ♪
♪ 夢も希望もなく泣いた ♪
♪ 周りの人達がなぜだか ♪
♪ 輝いて見えた ♪
♪ 僕には何が出来る？ ♪
♪ 抱えたこともあった ♪
♪ あの時の辛さがあったからこそ ♪
♪ 今があるのかな ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 辛かったあの時の思いも ♪
♪ ここから飛ばしてしまおう ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 夢と現実どっちかって ♪
♪ そりゃ夢に決まってんだろ ♪
♪ マイライフ 支えてくれた仲間や ♪
♪ 応援してくれた仲間が ♪
♪ 僕の背中押してから ♪
♪ あの山を目指しだした ♪
♪ あれから流れる時が ♪
♪ メロディに乗って音が ♪
♪ 波に乗りいつか ♪
♪ 皆の希望に変わる日が ♪
♪ 悔しくて涙した ♪
♪ 馬鹿にだって何度された ♪
♪ 自分の力不足になぜだか ♪
♪ 嫌気が差してきた ♪
♪ 人よりも不器用な ♪
♪ 僕は誰かに選ばれた ♪
♪ もう一人だけの夢じゃないんだ ♪
♪ みんなの夢が詰まってんだ ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 辛かったあの時の思いも ♪
♪ ここから飛ばしてしまおう ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 夢と現実どっちかって ♪
♪ そりゃ夢に決まってんだろ ♪
♪マイライフ はじめから諦めて ♪
♪ 無理だって決め付けて ♪
♪ イエーイ
それでは晴れてるハズの空も色あせて ♪
♪ 諦めないで ♪
♪ あの上を目指して ♪
♪ 必ずたどり着くから ♪
♪ 出来るから ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 辛かったあの時の思いも ♪
♪ ここから飛ばしてしまおう ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 夢と現実どっちかって ♪
♪ そりゃ夢に決まってんだろ
マイライフ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 辛かったあの時の思いも ♪
♪ ここから飛ばしてしまおう ♪
♪ 夢どこまでも追って ♪
♪ あの山の頂上登って ♪
♪ 夢と現実どっちかって ♪
♪ そりゃ夢に決まってんだろ
マイライフ ♪
♪ マライ マライ マライ マライ ・・・ ♪
♪ ノーマライ ノーマライゼーション ♪
♪ この世に差別を無くすことだろう ♪
♪ イエーイ ヘーイ ♪
♪ イエーイ ♪
ありがとうございました
（拍手）